the 20/20 Karen's cup is the strongest
women's tournament ever held in the
United States tell me a little bit about
how this impacts women in chess everyone
wants to play in Ken's Cup because of
price yes turn tournament and the good
atmosphere I think it's very important
to help such strong tournaments because
actually I rarely play against strong
players I mean it has a tournaments the
rating of my opponents quite low and
it's really very hard to progress in
your head you have this ideas to play
good and to be invited for the next year
it helps woman's chest because in the
past that there's not some strong woman
orientation tournament and cons Cup and
this year it's a very strong every trade
against about he's over 2500 so this is
one of the best event for women's chest
especially it has such big prize fun and
prestigious to participate here I'm glad
to be here in the second edition too so
I and I am definitely sure that this is
going to be every year somehow I'm more
confident I think it will definitely
encourage more and more players to be
part of this it motivates young girls it
shows that it's possible if you play
chess well to be invited to such great
events I think this is one of the
world's best tournament with the highest
prize fund for women so definitely this
even has motivated many men chess
players hopefully a lot of people watch
and like be inspired by the fact that we
have such like a strong field here well
the Karen's Cup is a big step forward
for women's chess I mean as tournaments
with like the biggest prize fund for
women in the world and it's giving a
chance to showcase that the games are
the best female players around the world
so it's a very exciting to be part of
this
you